This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. You may have seen a Nukuchi table. Actually, I know you've seen it. It's like the coffee table. In movies or TV shows when they want to show that a lawyer or an art dealer is really sophisticated, they put a Nukuchi table in their waiting room.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。你可能见过野口桌。事实上，我敢说你一定见过。就像那个咖啡桌一样。在电影或电视剧中，当他们想表现某个律师或艺术品商人格外精明时，就会在候客室里放一张野口桌。
And it is really a beautiful table. Two curvy wooden legs interlock and support this heavy slab of glass, which seems like it's almost floating above them. That's reporter Jackson Roach. Since the Naguchi coffee table was introduced in 1948, it's become one of the emblems of mid-century industrial design. It has its own Wikipedia page, and there's a thriving Instagram hashtag hashtag f-y-n-c-t which stands for F**k Your Noguchi Coffee Table which basically means F**k Your Fuji Klee Che interiors Which is ironic because like all eventual Klee Shays
而且这确实是一张漂亮的桌子。两只曲线优美的木质桌腿相互交错，支撑着一块厚重的玻璃板，它看起来几乎像是悬浮在桌腿上方。这是记者杰克逊·罗奇。自从野口咖啡桌于1948年问世以来，它就成为了世纪中叶工业设计的标志之一。它有自己的维基百科页面，还有一个热门的Instagram标签，叫做“去你的野口咖啡桌”，这基本上意思就是去你的克利谢风格室内设计，这很讽刺，因为就像所有最终沦为俗套的事物一样
Noguchi himself was quite of unguard Noguchi was a prodigy, a sculpting prodigy Isamu Noguchi was a sculptor, and he was so much more than that. Choreographers and fashion designers and art directors, and a whole lot of different people across a really wide creative swath looked at Niguchi as a point of inspiration. This is Dakin Hart, Senior Curator of the Isamu Noguchi Foundation and Garden Museum. Noguchi himself built this studio in Queens to house a lifetime of his abstract, evocative experiments in stone and metal.
野口本人其实挺特立独行的。野口是个奇才，一个雕塑奇才。野口勇是一位雕塑家，但他远不止于此。编舞家、时装设计师、艺术指导，以及横跨极广的创意领域的各种各样的人，都将野口视为灵感的源泉。这是野口勇基金会及花园博物馆的高级策展人达金·哈特。野口本人在皇后区建造了这个工作室，用来容纳他一生中在石头和金属领域进行的抽象而富有感染力的实验。
Hart says Noguchi was challenging himself with every sculpture. Can I make something hard feel soft? Can I make something heavy feel light? Can I make something heavy feel light? Can I make something far away feel like it's right next to you? You know, to make rock feel fluid that way. Noguchi's sculptures seem to twist and balance on themselves, undulating with form and texture, but this is all his later work.
哈特说，野口在每一件雕塑中都在挑战自己。我能让坚硬的东西感觉柔软吗？我能让沉重的东西感觉轻盈吗？我能让沉重的东西感觉轻盈吗？我能让遥远的东西感觉就像在你的眼前吗？你知道的，就是让岩石呈现出那种流动的质感。野口的雕塑似乎在自身上扭曲并保持平衡，随着形态和纹理起伏，但这都是他后期的作品。
Back in the 1930s, before Noguchi had a signature museum and a namesake coffee table, he was a struggling artist in New York City. He paid the bills by sculpting busts of rich people. He called it headbusting, and he did it just to make money. Or he said he did it just to make money. But in truth, he used it brilliantly as a way to social network.
回到20世纪30年代，在野口拥有以自己名字命名的博物馆和同名咖啡桌之前，他只是纽约市一名苦苦挣扎的艺术家。他通过为富人雕刻半身像来支付账单。他称之为“毁头像”，他做这个纯粹是为了赚钱。或者他说他做这个纯粹是为了赚钱。但事实上，他出色地利用这一点作为社交网络的一种方式。
And it was a way to romance the people who were his patrons. Noguchi was as great a networker as he was a sculptor, but headbusting wasn't exactly fulfilling. He wanted to think bigger. Here's Noguchi in an interview from the 70s. In 1933, about having done some more heads and so forth and being disgusted with doing heads, one has desire to get away, you know, to another dimension, I suppose the same thing that makes us go to the moon, desire to get away.
这也是一种与他的赞助人建立浪漫关系的方式。野口既是一个出色的社交高手，也是一位杰出的雕塑家，但“毁头像”并不是那么令人满足。他想要思考得更大。这是野口在70年代的一次采访中的发言。1933年，在做了一些更多的头像等等之后，对做头像感到厌烦，你就会有一种想要离开的欲望，你知道的，去另一个维度，我想这就和让我们登月的是同一回事，一种想要离开的欲望。
Nuhuchi wanted to make art that would live in the world, not just in a rich person's home or on a gallery wall. He wanted to change the physical landscape that people moved through. Noguchi said that he wanted people to feel like the first person on Earth, the first person to explore Earth. And so he started to think of a concept for a giant public sculpture. It looked like a massive, massive pyramid. Imagine a cross between a Mayan temple and a mountain
野口想要创作能够融入现实世界的艺术，而不仅仅是挂在富人家里或画廊墙壁上。他想要改变人们所处的物理景观。野口曾说，他想让人们感觉自己就像地球上的第一个人，第一个探索地球的人。于是他开始构思一个巨大的公共雕塑的概念。它看起来像一座庞大无比的金字塔。想象一下玛雅神庙和山的结合体
pushing up out of the earth with a long slide sloping down it and steps on two of its faces. It is a step pyramid, essentially, but on each side, the steps are different heights and they're regular, They're asymmetrical. But it wasn't just a sculpture for a museum or a bank plaza. Noguchi thought of it as a playground. He called it play mountain.
从大宗土地上拔地而起，一条长长的滑梯顺势而下，两面都有台阶。从本质上讲，它是一个阶梯金字塔，但在每一侧，台阶的高度都不同，而且是不规则的，它们是不对称的。但这不仅仅是为博物馆或银行广场创作的雕塑。野口把它想象成一个游乐场。他称之为“游戏山”。
So he talked about play as the primer for a purposeful approach to space, trying to teach people to be more mindful of space and how we occupy it, and how it works. This giant ziggurat wouldn't come with any specific instructions. We'd have no rules, no single obvious way to play with it. Neguchi wanted Play Mountain to be a strange new landscape that would dare children to imagine other realities, so that perhaps they could grow up into creative, open-minded adults. And I think Niguchi hoped that by making playgrounds, he could impact people at that key stage in development.
所以他谈到游戏是通往有目的的空间方法的入门，试图教导人们更加关注空间、我们如何占据空间以及它是如何运作的。这座巨大的阶梯金字塔不会附带任何具体的说明。我们将没有规则，没有单一显而易见的方式来玩它。野口希望“游戏山”成为一个奇异的新景观，能够激发孩子们去想象其他现实，这样他们也许就能成长为富有创造力、思想开放的成年人。而且我认为野口希望通过建造游乐场，能够在发展的关键阶段对人们产生影响。
In fact, the inspiration for Play Mountain came to Niguchi when he was at this key stage himself, when he was a little boy. Asamu Noguchi was born in Los Angeles in 1904. His father Yone was a famous Japanese poet, and his mother was a white American writer named Leoni Gilmour. They met when she answered an ad he placed in the paper for a translator and assistant.
事实上，“游戏山”的灵感是在野口自己处于这个关键阶段时，也就是当他还是个小男孩的时候产生的。野口勇于1904年出生于洛杉矶。他的父亲野口米吉郎是一位著名的日本诗人，他的母亲是一位名叫莱昂妮·吉尔摩的白人美国作家。他们相遇时，莱昂妮应聘了野口米吉郎在报纸上刊登的寻找翻译兼助手的广告。
Pretty much as soon as Asamu was born, Yone abandoned them and went back to Japan. Naguchi and his mother eventually followed, but his father had already started another family by then. So Naguchi and his mother moved to a countryside town where Naguchi's bright blue eyes marked him as an outsider to the other kids at school. His childhood was pretty lonely. But from their little house in the little town they lived in on the seaside, they did have a great view of Mt. Fuji, but Fuji quite far away, so like just the perfect little pyramid. So you can imagine that view that's a little boy has every day going down the stairs seeing Mt. Fuji.
几乎在野口勇出生后不久，父亲米吉郎就抛弃了他们回到了日本。野口和他的母亲最终也跟了过去，但他的父亲那时已经组建了另一个家庭。于是野口和母亲搬到了一个乡村小镇，野口那双亮蓝色的眼睛让他成了学校里其他孩子眼中的局外人。他的童年相当孤独。但从他们在海滨小镇居住的小房子的里，他们确实能看到富士山的绝佳风景，富士山离得很远，就像一个小小的完美金字塔。所以你可以想象那个小男孩每天下楼时看到富士山的那个情景。
That idea of his own Mt. Fuji stuck with Niguchi. It followed him when he moved to Indiana as a teenager. It followed him to Paris where he apprenticed with the sculptor Brancuzzi. And it came with him to New York City. The place that he decided would become his home. So it was like imagine taking Mount Fuji and turning it into a giant place structure. I think that's what Play Mountain was. Niguchi wrote, Play Mountain was my response based upon memory of my own unhappy childhood, the desolate playground on a cliff in Tokyo, which I approached with dread.
那种属于他自己的富士山的理念一直留在野口心中。当他十几岁搬到印第安纳州时，它一直跟随著他。它跟着他去了巴黎，在那里他师从雕塑家布朗库西。它也和他一起来到了纽约市。这个他决定将其作为自己家的地方。所以这就像是想象把富士山变成一个巨大的游乐设施。我想这就是“游戏山”的模样。野口写道，“游戏山”是我的回应，基于我自己不幸童年的记忆，东京悬崖上荒凉的游乐场，我带着恐惧接近它。
It may be that this is how I tried to join the city, New York, to belong. Nuguchi wanted to move the mountain from his lonely childhood and reincarnate it as a place for gathering and playing, as a kind of gift to the children of New York. And after years and years of carrying that concept in his head, he got his big break. In 1934, one of the fancy people Noguchi had made a bust of helped him get a meeting
也许这就是我试图融入纽约这座城市并找到归属感的方式。野口想要把孤独童年里那座山搬过来，将其转世为人们聚集和玩耍的地方，作为对纽约孩子的一种礼物。在脑海中揣着这个概念年复一年之后，他终于迎来了他的重大突破。1934年，野口为其制作过半身像的一位上流人士帮他安排了一次会面
with Robert Moses, the newly appointed commissioner of the New York City Parks Department. Moses had said his number one priority was to build more playgrounds in the city, which at the time had very few. So Noguchi decided to bring him his idea. Noguchi brought Moses a model of play mountain, two feet square made of white plaster on a wooden frame, designed to take up an entire New York City block. Nguncgi carries this miniature mountain
对象是罗伯特·摩西，新任纽约市公园局局长。摩西曾表示，他的首要任务是在全市建造更多游乐场，当时全市的游乐场少之又少。于是野口决定把他的想法带给摩西。野口给摩西带去了一个“游戏山”的模型，两英尺见方，由木框架上的白色石膏制成，设计得占据整整一个纽约街区。野口扛着这座微型山
to Robert Moses' office and thunks it down on Robert Moses' desk. And says, what if we built this for the children of the city? This is Alexandra Lang, architecture critic at Curved and author of the design of childhood. And Moses' like no way. The playgrounds Moses envisioned were simple. Asphalt or dirt surrounded by chain link fence
来到罗伯特·摩西的办公室，把它“咚”地一声砸在罗伯特·摩西的桌子上。并说，如果我们为城市的儿童建造这个怎么样？这是《Curbed》的建筑评论家、《童年设计》的作者亚历山德拉·朗。而摩西的反应是没门。摩西设想的游乐场很简单。四周环绕着铁丝网的沥青地或泥土地
with the four S's of playground equipment. Swings, slide, sandbox, seesaw, all made out of steel. Moses was planning just to plonk these four S's in vacant lots all over the city by the hundreds. And here comes Neguchi with this massive, ambiguous, otherworldly urban mountain, which would have required the movement of huge amounts of earth and concrete, and probably would have cost a ton of money. And he just left his head off and threw us out more than he was. and all through his outlaw. Like, no way, dope. Like, I, for S's, I'm just going to order them.
配备了游乐设备的四大金刚：秋千、滑梯、沙坑、跷跷板，全部由钢铁制成。摩西正计划把这四大金刚成百上千地直接塞进全市的空地里。而野口却带着这座巨大、含糊不清、超凡脱俗的城市大山来了，这需要移动大量的泥土和混凝土，而且可能会花一大笔钱。他脑子一热，把我们抛诸脑后，根本不理睬他。而且完全不听他的。就像是，没门，门儿都没有。就像，什么四大金刚，我直接采购就行了。
And like, we're going to have, you know, 400 playgrounds by tomorrow. Robert Moses did end up erecting 658 playgrounds in New York as part's commissioner. But from this moment on, he and Nguci became lifelong enemies. He took his model and went home, fuming. And he fumed about it for the rest of his life, really.
而且就像，你知道的，我们明天就会有400个游乐场。罗伯特·摩西最终作为公园局局长在纽约建造了658个游乐场。但从这一刻起，他和野口成了终死宿敌。他拿着模型回家了，气得火冒三丈。而且他在余生中真的都在为这件事生气。
The concept of play mountain remained very close to Noguchi's heart. As Noguchi himself wrote, play mountain was the kernel out of which have grown all my ideas relating sculpture to the earth. Play Mountain represented this idea that Noguchi had. The children didn't need instructions to play. With, say, swings or a slide, there's only one way to use them. And kids just do the same prescribed activities over and over again. But if you give children an abstract, surreal landscape,
“游戏山”的概念在野口心中一直分量极重。正如野口本人所写，“游戏山”是我所有将雕塑与大地联系起来的想法所孕育出的核心。游戏山代表了野口的这个理念。孩子们玩耍并不需要说明书。比如玩秋千或滑梯，使用方法只有一种。而孩子们只是在机械地一遍又一遍重复相同的规定动作。但如果你给孩子们一个抽象、超现实的景观，
they can interpret it however they want. They can make up stories and have adventures and use their intuition to play in a thousand different ways. This philosophy would later be called non-directive play. For Noguchi, this was the way that sculpture could be out in the world and really change the way people move and think. He wasn't going to give up on it so easily. In 1939, Noguchi offered to design a playground for Honolulu's
他们就可以随心所欲地解读它。他们可以编造故事，进行冒险，并用他们的直觉以成千上万种不同的方式玩耍。这种哲学后来被称为非指导性游戏。对野口来说，这就是雕塑走向世界并真正改变人们行动和思考方式的途径。他不会那么轻易放弃。1939年，野口提出为檀香山的
Ola-Muana Park. But that fell through. Still not discouraged, Noguchi pitches his Hawaii playground ideas back to the New York Parks Department. Again, again he gets rejected. But Noguchi is relentless. And so Noguchi, still excited by the challenge went off in design contour playground. Contour playground is really gentle. Basically a smooth, abstracted landscape of sloping hills and dails and riverbeds. It's still a non-directive playground, but it's very subtle. This time, the New York Park's department actually seems open to it.
阿拉莫阿那公园设计一个游乐场。但那次计划泡汤了。野口并没有气馁，他又把他在夏威夷游乐场的想法推销给纽约公园局。结果再次被拒绝。但野口是执着的。于是野口依然对这个挑战充满热情，去设计了“轮廓游乐场”。“轮廓游乐场”非常温和。基本上是一个平缓的、由起伏的山丘、山谷和河床组成的抽象景观。它仍然是一个非指导性游乐场，但非常微妙。这一次，纽约公园局似乎真的对它持开放态度。
They even start talking about finding a spot in Central Park to build it. But by then, the year was 1941, and Noguchi's plans were about to change. Noguchi was in California, visiting a friend, and he was out shopping for some onyx for a sculpture. In fact, I was on my way to San Diego, and I happened to know the radio, and that's where I headed. he was out shopping for some onyx for a sculpture. Nisei or Americans born to Japanese parents. With the US entering World War II, Contrard playground was forgotten by both the Parks Department and Ngochi. There were bigger stakes now.
他们甚至开始讨论在中央公园找个地方来建造它。但到了那时，时间已经是1941年，野口的计划即将改变。野口当时在加利福尼亚探望朋友，他正在为一件雕塑采购一些缟玛瑙。事实上，我当时正在去圣迭戈的路上，我碰巧听了收音机，那就是我前往的方向。他当时正在为一件雕塑采购一些缟玛瑙。日裔美国人，即在美国出生的日本父母的后代。随着美国卷入二战，“轮廓游乐场”被公园局和野口双双遗忘。现在有更重大的利害关系了。
I thought I would be able to help in some way. Ngochi started to link up with other Nisei, looking for ways to make it clear to the government that they were firmly on the American side of the war. So we had these meetings and we know that our intention was that we would counteract the bad press to stop kind of hysteria and this developing. But that hysteria was quickly coming to a head. Barely two months after Pearl Harbor, President Roosevelt signed executive order
我以为我能以某种方式帮上忙。野口开始与其他日裔美国人联系，寻找向政府表明他们坚定站在战争美国这一边的方法。所以我们开了这些会议，我们知道我们的目的是为了抵制负面新闻，阻止这种歇斯底里的情绪及其发展。但这种歇斯底里很快就达到了白热化。珍珠港事件发生仅仅两个月后，罗斯福总统签署了行政命令
9066. Executive order 9666 gives the American military the right to declare martial law in any of part of the country that it deems necessary to protect the homeland. And that's with the understanding that in the Western United States they would round up the Japanese American population. Evacuation orders with fast approaching deadlines started landing on people's doorsteps. And we had to get out of California, you know, everybody had to get out. Including me, I had to get out, a higher abandon my car and Los Angeles and flew out, came to New York.
9066。行政命令9066赋予美国军方在他们认为保护国土有必要的该国任何地区宣布戒严的权利。这就意味着，在美洲西部，他们将把日裔美国人驱逐并集中起来。迫在眉睫的疏散令开始落到人们的门廊上。我们不得不离开加利福尼亚，你知道的，每个人都必须离开。包括我，我也必须离开，我不得不抛弃我在洛杉矶的车，坐飞机离开了，来到了纽约。
Nuguchi had always been good at finding exactly the right person for the moment. In this moment, he needed someone to help him take action, and so he found him in Washington, DC. So I went to Washington, you know, went around inquiring whether or not I can do. Finally, I happened to bump into John Collier. John Collier was the head of the Bureau of Indian Affairs. Because the government needed to build the internment camps in large, open areas of federally controlled land,
野口一直很擅长为特定时刻找到正合适的人。在这个时刻，他需要有人来帮助他采取行动，于是他在华盛顿特区找到了这样一个人。所以我去了华盛顿，你知道的，到处打听我是否能做点什么。最后，我碰巧遇到了约翰·科利尔。约翰·科利尔是印第安人事务局的局长。由于政府需要在联邦控制土地的大片开阔区域建立拘留营，
they decided to build two of them on Native American reservations, which meant that the actual undertaking of building and running these camps would fall to John Collier's department. John Collier was relatively progressive. He wanted to give tribal governments more autonomy and support Native American culture. And then suddenly, he had been given the task of designing and building prison camps on reservation land. Ngu Chi reached out to him. Ngu Chi and Collier started talking about what they could do with this assignment,
他们决定在美洲原住民保留地上建造其中两个，这意味着建造和运营这些营地的实际任务将落在约翰·科利尔的部门肩上。约翰·科利尔相对比较开明。他希望赋予部族政府更多自治权并支持美洲原住民文化。而突然之间，他被委派了在保留地土地上设计和建造监狱营的任务。野口联系了他。野口和科利尔开始讨论他们能为这个任务做些什么，
now that there was no way to prevent internment from happening. They cooked up and this is going to sound so crazy, but in a way they cooked up what was a utopian scheme, because from their point of view if it's going to happen, let's make it as good as it can possibly be. Naguchi drew up a suite of plans for the largest of the camps being built, the one at Poston, Arizona. I made plans for the park development and this and that and the other, to make it into a park like this. Noguchi took the rigid grid of a military style camp with rows and rows of tar paper barracks and cut an avenue right down the middle of it, lined with public services, schools and
既然已经无法阻止拘留的发生。他们炮制了一个方案——这听起来可能太疯狂了，但从某种角度来看，他们炮制的是一个乌托邦式的计划，因为从他们的角度来看，既然事情非发生不可，那就把它做到我们能力范围内的最好。野口为正在建造的最大的营地——亚利桑那州波斯顿营地起草了一套规划。我为公园开发画了图纸，还有这个那个的，把它变成这样一个公园。野口将军事风格营地的僵硬网格——布满一排排焦油纸营房——从正中间切出了一条大道，两旁排列着公共服务设施、学校和
gardens, a hospital, restaurants, a department store, and a movie theater, and a church, and a cemetery, and a zoo, botanical garden, sports fields, and a mini golf course, and playgrounds. What you're looking at is what he thinks the key parts of civilization are. You have a huge population of people who have been removed from their lives and artificially plonked down in the middle of nowhere where they are expected to live. Quotum Quot, what does that mean? What is a life?
花园、医院、餐馆、百货公司、电影院、教堂、墓地、动物园、植物园、运动场、迷你高尔夫球场和游乐场。你看到的是他认为文明的关键部分。你有一大群人，他们被从生活中剥离出来，硬生生地塞到了荒郊野岭，在那里他们被期望活下去。引号引号，那是什么意思？生活是什么？
What does life consist of? How, what does it need to be real? To feel real? The playground is critical to it. The plans themselves are pretty unbelievable, but the really wild thing is that even though Japanese internment only affected people living on the west coast, and Noguchi was living on the east coast, Noguchi and Collier decide Noguchi should actually go to this concentration camp in Post-San Arizona,
生活由什么组成？如何，它需要什么才能成为真实的？去感受真实？游乐场对此至关重要。这些规划本身简直不可思议，但真正疯狂的是，尽管日裔拘留只影响了生活在西海岸的人们，而野口当时住在东海岸，但野口和科利尔决定，野口实际上应该去亚利桑那州波斯顿的这个集中营，
voluntarily, and live there while he carried out his plan. And that's how I happen to go to Poston. The camp was being constructed in the middle of the desert, in the southwestern part of Arizona, on the Colorado River Indian Reservation. There was hardly anything for miles around just rubby brush and dust, mountains in the far distance. So Niyuchi got to post in like a week before it opened. So I was on the people getting the place ready. And all the people were coming in there to help,
自愿前往，并在执行他的计划的同时住在那里。这就是我碰巧去波斯顿的原因。该营地正处于亚利桑那州西南部沙漠的正中央建设中，位于科罗拉多河印第安人保留地上。方圆几英里内几乎没有什么东西，只有灌木丛和尘土，远处的群山。所以野口在营地开放前大约一周到达了波斯顿。所以我当时是帮着把这个地方准备好的人之一。所有的人都到那里去帮忙，
you see. And I was among them. Nuguchi was given his own room and thought he'd soon be getting to work on realizing his vision for a utopian community. I mean, this was a guy who plonged play mountain down in front of Robert Moses and said, let's build this for kids. His strange hopefulness, new no limits.
你看。我就是其中之一。野口分到了一间属于他自己的房间，以为他很快就能开始着手实现他对乌托邦社区的愿景。我的意思是，这家伙可是把“游戏山”往罗伯特·摩西面前一扔，说，给孩子们建个这个吧。他那奇异的乐观情绪，毫无止境。
But as soon as the camp opened, it became painfully clear to Nguuqi that the people weren't coming there for an endilic new lifestyle. They were prisoners. To the camp administrators from the War Relocation Authority, Noguchi looked just like another one of the prisoners. They wouldn't give him the time of day. And because he had some special privileges, the other in Ternese assumed he was this traitor
但就在营地开放后不久，野口痛苦地发现，人们来这里并不是为了过上田园诗般的新生活。他们是囚犯。对于战争搬迁管理局的营地管理人员来说，野口看起来就像另一个囚犯。他们根本不搭理他。而因为他拥有一些特权，其他被扣押人员则认为他是叛徒，
and kahuts with the camp administrators. He immediately realized he was sort of the worst of both worlds because he was just an attorney from the administration's point of view. And he was a turncoat like a spy from the other attorney's point of view. After about two months at Post-In, Nikuchi realized that the War Relocation Authority had no interest in making it a nice place to live. They ran it like a prison camp. Because it was a prison camp. Because it was a prison camp. All of John Collier's
与营地管理者勾结在一起。他立刻意识到自己处于两面不讨好的最糟糕境地，因为从管理层的角度来看，他只是一名被扣押人员；而从其他被扣押人员的角度来看，他是个叛徒，就像个间谍。在波斯顿呆了大约两个月后，野口意识到战争搬迁管理局对把这里变成一个宜居的好地方毫无兴趣。他们像管理监狱营一样管理这里。因为这里就是一座监狱营。因为这里就是一座监狱营。约翰·科利尔和
and Nikuchi's idealistic plans were ignored. Seeing that there was no chance of doing what he'd come to do, Nikuchi decided to move on. He figured he'd just go back to normal life, being a famous artist and hanging out with his famous artist friends. And they wouldn't let him leave. Which was definitely not a part of the plan. He had no idea that he wouldn't be able to leave. So I was definitely going to get off of several monsters and I didn't let me be very uncomfortable. Neguchi was suddenly a prisoner. Having made enemies of internees and administrators alike, he spent most of his time alone with
野口的理想主义计划全都被忽略了。眼看着没有机会去做他来这里要做的事，野口决定继续前行。他盘算着自己可以回去过正常生活，继续当他的名艺术家，和他的艺术家名流朋友们厮混。而他们却不让他离开。这绝对不在计划之内。他根本不知道自己无法离开。所以我本来以为几个月就能脱身，而他们不让我走，这让我非常难受。野口突然成了一个囚犯。由于同时得罪了被扣押人员和管理者，他大部分时间都孤身一人，
nothing to do. Posting was a bleak, barren place. Almost every day there was triple digit heat and huge dust storms tearing through, coming in through the thin walls of the barracks, getting stuck in your bed and your mouth and your eyes. Noguchi wrote to one of his famous friends, the artist Manray, quote,
无事可做。波斯顿是一个阴冷、荒凉的地方。几乎每天都有三位数的高温和巨大的沙尘暴肆虐，从营房薄薄的墙壁钻进来，钻进你的床铺、你的嘴里和你的眼睛里。野口写信给他的艺术家名流朋友曼雷，引述道：
here time has stopped and nothing is of any consequence, nothing of any value. Neither are time or our skill. The world is nuts. After seven months and many, many letters and phone calls, John Collier was able to get Noguchi out. After seven months, I got out of the pass. And he never went back. It's hard to know what to make of Naguchi's failed mission to post in, and it kind of leads to this deeper question.
在这里，时间已经停止，一切都毫无意义，没有任何价值。无论是时间还是我们的技能。这个世界疯了。在七个月以及无数次的信件和电话沟通后，约翰·科利尔终于把野口弄了出去。七个月后，我离开了波斯顿。他再也没有回去过。很难对野口失败的波斯顿之行作何评价，这自然而然地引出了一个更深层次的问题。
Does it even make sense to try to find joy or beauty or playfulness in a system that's just fundamentally awful? You know, trying to make a prison better when the prison shouldn't exist. Critic Alexander Lang again. Like he thought he could make this internment camp more humane, but it's an inhumane endeavor. The whole experience was painful for Neguchi. His goals had been so compassionate going in, but racism and fear and bureaucracy killed those dreams
在一个本质上糟糕透顶的系统中，试图寻找快乐、美丽或玩耍的心态，这真的有意义吗？你知道的，试图去改善一座本不该存在的监狱。再次引用评论家亚历山德拉·朗的话。就像他以为自己能让这个拘留营更有人情味一点，但这是一项本身就不人道的事业。整个经历对野口来说是痛苦的。他最初的目标是如此富有同情心，但种族主义、恐惧和官僚主义扼杀了这些梦想，
and then imprisoned him when he tried to help. When I finally landed back in New York in 1942, it must have seemed wrong somehow. Like, how could you think about play when there's so much cruelty in the world? In fact, in 1943, the year after Noguchi gets out of post-in, he makes this sculpture called this tortured earth, which is like the nightmare version of his model for contoured playground,
并在他试图提供帮助时将他监禁起来。当我最终在1942年回到纽约时，这一切肯定在某种程度上显得不对劲。就像，当世界上有这么多残酷的事情时，你怎么还能去考虑玩耍？事实上，在1943年，也就是野口离开波斯顿的第二年，他创作了一件名为《饱受折磨的大地》的雕塑，这就像是他的“轮廓游乐场”模型的噩梦版本，
a twisted landscape that looks like it's been stabbed and torn with a knife. But once he was back in New York, Noguchi put post in behind him. He threw himself into the art scene. He's designing furniture, he's making sculpture, he's building a career in New York City. Noguchi steps back from his utopian ideas about art and sculpture. And this is the period when he designed some of the things he's most famous for today, including the iconic coffee table. Niguchi's career in sculpture really took off, and he also got to design other kinds of
一个扭曲的景观，看起来像被刀刺伤和撕裂过一样。但回到纽约后，野口把波斯顿抛在了脑后。他全身心投入到艺术界中。他设计家具，创作雕塑，在纽约市建立自己的职业生涯。野口从他关于艺术和雕塑的乌托邦理念中退了一步。正是在这段时期，他设计了一些当今最著名的作品，包括那张标志性的咖啡桌。野口在雕塑领域的职业生涯真正腾飞了，他还得以设计其他类型的
environments. He designed dance sets for Martha Graham and sculpture gardens for corporations like IBM and Chase Bank. He was schmoozing up the storm, becoming a household name and a real star of mid-century art and design. Still, Nukuchi has that hunger in his soul for something more meaningful than the New York art scene. He still wants to make something
环境。他为玛莎·葛兰姆设计了舞蹈布景，并为IBM和大通银行等企业设计了雕塑花园。他左右逢源，声名鹊起，成为了世纪中叶艺术与设计的真正明星。尽管如此，野口的心灵深处仍然对更有意义的事物有着一种饥渴。他仍然想创造一些
that can transcend a gallery space. And that is because, again, I have this feeling that sculpture was an important part of the living experience, you see, and not something for electives to buy. After a decade of looking inward, indulging in the adoration of the art world and recovering from post-in, Noguchi turns his sights back to playgrounds. We couldn't shake that realization that he'd had, that playgrounds were actually the perfect
能够超越画廊空间的事物。那是因为，再次强调，我有这样一种感觉，即雕塑是生活体验的重要组成部分，你看，而不是供特权阶层购买的东西。在经历了十年向内看、沉浸在艺术界的崇拜中以及从波斯顿的阴影中恢复过来之后，野口将目光重新投回了游乐场。他无法摆脱那个意识：游乐场实际上是雕塑家在世界上做出真正改变的绝佳途径。
way for a sculptor to make real change in the world. So we tried two more times to build playgrounds for New York, once in 1950 at the new UN building, and another in the early 60s in Riverside Park. And again, Noguchi's playground plans were shot down by the city. But something was different in this round of rejections, because Noguchi was now mega-famous. Everyone in the art world had heard all about his rejected playground designs. They'd been written up in newspapers, and the models were displayed in museums. So other architects, artists, and designers started copying them.
于是他又尝试了两次为纽约建造游乐场，一次是在1950年的新联合国大楼，另一次是在60年代初的河滨公园。而野口的游乐场规划再次被纽约市否决。但在这一轮拒绝中情况有所不同，因为野口现在已经是超级巨星了。艺术界的每个人都听说过他被拒绝的游乐场设计。它们被写进报纸，模型也在博物馆里展出。因此，其他建筑师、艺术家和设计师开始模仿它们。
So there are a fair number of people in the 50s and 60s making abstract concrete forms and saying that they are for children. It becomes a movement, a whole strand of playground design that Niguchi kind of founded. Alexander Lang calls this the abstractionist strand. You can play with an abstract form any way you want. And imagine it as anything you like. These shapes can become anything in your mind. In the 60s and 70s, designers, artists, and architects
所以在50和60年代，有相当多的在制作抽象的混凝土形式，并声称它们是为孩子们准备的。这成了一场运动，一种由野口开创的游乐场设计的整体潮流。亚历山德拉·朗称之为抽象主义潮流。你可以用任何你喜欢的方式来玩抽象的形状。并把它想象成你喜欢的任何东西。在60和70年代，设计师、艺术家和建筑师
build abstract playgrounds all over the world, climbing arches and stepping stones at Amsterdam, blobby triple slides in Austria, webs of steel and rope in Japan. And in the US, modular octahedrons and pixelated wooden landscapes, all made by famous architects, designing and building abstract, non-directive playgrounds.
在世界各地建造抽象的游乐场：阿姆斯特丹的攀爬拱门和踏脚石，奥地利胖乎乎的三联滑梯，日本的钢铁和绳索网。在美国，则是模块化的八面体和像素化的木质景观，全部由著名的建筑师设计和建造，打造抽象、非指导性的游乐场。
Even Noguchi himself was able to build some abstract-ish sculptural playground equipment in the 60s and 70s. You know, Noguchi was one of the first people to say that and make those things and kind of taking children seriously as connoisseurs of form in a way. It would seem like the perfect time for Noguchi to build the thing he wanted his whole life. The true play mountain vision of something that could turn landscapes into massive abstract forms. But just as it seems, Niguchi's ideas are gaining traction,
甚至野口本人在60和70年代也得以建造了一些偏向抽象的雕塑游乐设备。你知道的，野口是最早说出那些话并制造那些东西的人之一，在某种程度上把孩子们当作形式的鉴赏家来认真对待。这似乎是野口建造他一生梦寐以求之物的绝佳时机。真正的“游戏山”愿景，能将景观变成庞大的抽象形式。但正当野口的想法似乎获得关注时，
it's cut short. As the 60s turn to the 70s and the 70s draw to a close, the abstract playground movement goes underground. Because in the 1980s, the entire world of playground design in the US changed dramatically. After the break, why the abstractionist movement went underground, and why your neighborhood playground probably looks very similar to every other neighborhood playground. After this. A two-year-old boy named Frank Nelson
它却戛然而止。随着60年代过渡到70年代，70年代走向尾声，抽象游乐场运动转入了地下。因为在20世纪80年代，美国整个游乐场设计界发生了剧烈的变化。休息之后，我们将探讨为什么抽象主义运动会转入地下，以及为什么你家附近的游乐场看起来可能和其他所有社区的游乐场如此相似。广告之后见。一个两岁的小男孩名叫弗兰克·尼尔森
was climbing a 12-foot tall slide in a Chicago park, because that's just how tall slides used to be. He slipped through the railing off the steps and hit his head on hard asphalt. And has permanent brain damage. Frank became paralyzed on his left side. He had problems with vision and speech and had to wear a helmet to protect his fractured skull. So there's this big lawsuit where the park system of
当时正试图爬上芝加哥一个公园里12英尺高的滑梯，因为过去的滑梯就是那么高。他从台阶的栏杆处滑落，头部撞到了坚硬的沥青地面上。并导致永久性脑损伤。弗兰克身体左侧瘫痪。他有视力和言语问题，不得不戴着头盔来保护他骨折的头龙头骨。于是引发了一场轰动的大诉讼，芝加哥公园系统
Chicago has to pay out millions of dollars. Nine point five million dollars to be exact. The accident was in 1978 and it changed everything. At the time, there were no laws or real industry standards even when it came to the safety of playground equipment. But Frank Nelson's fall was one of a number of lawsuits that led the Consumer Product Safety Commission to publish the Handbook for Public Playground Safety in 1981. Then another standards organization, the ASTM, published its own guidelines. Pretty soon these rule books were in the hands of insurance companies and parks departments and school boards across the United States. And now to this day, almost all playgrounds have to be approved by certified playground safety inspectors.
必须支付数百万美元的赔偿金。准确地说是九百五十万美元。这起事故发生在1978年，它改变了一切。当时，甚至在游乐设备的安全方面，也没有任何法律或真正的行业标准。但弗兰克·尼尔森的坠落是导致消费品安全委员会在1981年发布《公共游乐场安全手册》的多起诉讼之一。随后，另一个标准组织ASTM发布了自己的指南。很快，这些规则手册就落入了全美各地的保险公司、公园部门和学校董事会手中。直到今天，几乎所有的游乐场都必须获得认证游乐场安全检查员的批准。
Hi, Craig Fetel with Safe to Play. Today I want to go over with you just a few of the things that I use to make sure that your playground is safe. This is a YouTube video that a certified playground safety inspector uses to advertise his services. He's standing on your typical modern playground and he has a bunch of these weirdly shaped metal objects on sticks. They're all different sizes, each approximating different child-sized body parts, a hand, foot, a head. Prove here, which could imitate head at nine inches, so the feet would go in and then the head would get stuck, so obviously we don't want that to happen.
嗨，我是来自“安全玩耍”公司的克雷格·费特尔。今天我想和大家一起回顾几件我用来确保你们的游乐场安全的东西。这是一段YouTube视频，一位认证的游乐场安全检查员用它来宣传他的服务。他站在典型的现代游乐场上，手里拿着一堆形状奇怪、插在棍子上的金属物体。它们大小各异，每一种都近似于不同儿童大小的身体部位：手、脚、头。这里有个探头，可以模拟九英寸的头，所以脚会进去，然后头就会卡住，所以很显然我们不希望这种情况发生。
And safety inspectors basically tried jamming these probes into every space or gap on a playground, looking for places where kids could fall or get pinched, poked or trapped. Obviously no one wants kids getting hurt on playgrounds. But as you might imagine, all these rules and regulations make the job of a playground designer a lot harder. Don't get me wrong, the job is fun as hell.
而安全检查员基本上会试图将这些探头塞进游乐场上的每一个空间或间隙中，寻找孩子们可能会跌倒、被夹住、被戳到或被困住的地方。显然没有人希望孩子们在游乐场受伤。但正如你所想象的，所有这些规章制度让游乐场设计师的工作变得困难得多。别误会我，这份工作有趣极了。
Tom Keller designs playgrounds. I look forward to coming in here every day because what a blast. But the more rules we have to adhere to, it just becomes more and more difficult, not impossible, but definitely more difficult to think outside the box. Tom works at landscape structures,
汤姆·凯勒负责设计游乐场。我每天都期待着来上班，因为这太爽了。但我们要遵守的规则越多，跳出固有思维框架就变得越来越困难，虽然不是不可能，但绝对更加困难。汤姆在明尼苏达州的
playground manufacturing company in Minnesota. And he says playground standards are so detailed that they end up ruling out almost all variation. In the cases of common playground equipment, swings, slides, springing equipment, and stuff like that, they truly create their own being because of the rules. It's going to look like this. A slide is a slide and your ability to alter that form is almost impossible. Theoretically, we love the idea of a special or unusual playground. Like, even within Tom's company, they want to manufacture beautiful new forms for kids to play on. Our executives, you know, they're like, well, we want a slide that nobody's ever thought of.
游乐场制造公司“景观结构”工作。他说，游乐场的标准是如此详细，以至于它们最终排除了几乎所有的变化。在常见的游乐设备案例中，秋千、滑梯、弹跳设备以及诸如此类的东西，由于规则的存在，它们真正创造了自己的存在形式。它最终就会长这样。滑梯就是滑梯，你想要改变这种形式几乎是不可能的。理论上，我们喜欢特殊或不寻常的游乐场的概念。就像，即使在汤姆的公司内部，他们也想为孩子们制造美观的新型游乐设施。我们的高管，你知道的，他们会说，嗯，我们要一个谁都没想过的滑梯。
You got to be more creative than that. And I'm like, guys, you know what? You don't want to read the rule book because that's going to bore you to death. But trust me, it is what it is. So the playgrounds that you see everywhere in neighborhood parks and school yards, they still all look more or less the same. The majority of playgrounds on the market today are what we refer to as post-index systems. Post-index systems are also called post-implatform playgrounds. And with those, you have decks and you have stairs and you have pathways. The post-implatform equipment essentially combines swing slide and monkey bars into one piece of equipment. They're elevated platforms made of plastic parts in bright primary colors. Sometimes the parts are connected with pathways covered with roofs, sometimes with bridges,
你们得更有创意一点。而我会说，伙计们，你知道吗？你们绝对不想去读那本规则手册，因为那会把你们无聊死。但相信我，事情就是这样。所以你在街区公园和学校操场到处都能看到的游乐场，它们看起来大体上都差不多。市场上绝大多数游乐场都是我们所说的“立柱平台系统”。立柱平台系统也被称为立柱平台游乐场。有了这些，你就会有平台、有楼梯和有通道。立柱平台设备本质上是将秋千、滑梯和攀爬架组合成了一件设备。它们是由明亮原色塑料部件制成的挑高平台。有时这些部件通过带有屋顶的通道连接，有时通过桥梁连接，
but there are steps and slides and ladders coming off the platforms at every turn. Blocking kids from being able to just kind of step off the platform into space. That agglomeration is kind of in response to the safety standards. Post and platform playgrounds definitely have more variety than the four S's that Robert Moses was in too. On the Moses style playgrounds, kids were just moving from one repetitive activity to the next. At least with post and platform structures, kids can make some decisions about
但到处都是从平台上延伸出来的台阶、滑梯和梯子。阻挡孩子们直接从平台踏空坠入虚空。这种组合某种程度上是为了响应安全标准。立柱平台游乐场肯定比罗伯特·摩西喜欢的那四大金刚有更多的变化。在摩西风格的游乐场上，孩子们只是从一个重复的活动移动到下一个。至少有了立柱平台结构，孩子们可以对如何上平台以及如何从平台上下来做出一些选择。
how to get onto the platform and then how to get down from it again. But still, post and platform playgrounds are all remixes of the same basic kit. It's time for a change a little bit. This is Scott Rochie, creative director at Landscape Structures. In addition to the standard playground kits, Landscape Structures also designs custom playgrounds for the clients that can afford them. And actually one of Scott's big inspirations is the work of Isamu Noguchi.
但即便如此，立柱平台游乐场也全都是同一套基本套件的重新混音。是时候做出一点改变了。这是“景观结构”公司的创意总监斯科特·罗奇。除了标准的游乐场套件外，“景观结构”还为负担得起的客户设计定制游乐场。事实上，斯科特最大的灵感来源之一就是野口勇的作品。
Designs of today are echoing a lot of what what Noguchi's concepts were. The kind of abstract playgrounds that Noguchi inspired are starting to re-emerge. We're starting to bring them back in a lot of custom playground design. For these special projects, Scott works with a lot of landscape architects, moving earth around and experimenting with new forms. We've been to playgrounds that we've designed that are very abstract and where parents literally say, I don't know how this is supposed to work. That's the best.
当今的设计在很大程度上呼应了野口的理念。野口所启发的这种抽象游乐场正在重新浮现。我们开始在许多定制游乐场设计中将它们带回来。对于这些特殊项目，斯科特与许多景观设计师合作，移动泥土并试验新的形式。我们去过我们设计的一些非常抽象的游乐场，那里的家长甚至会说：“我不知道这该怎么玩。”那是最棒的。
And this goes back to Niguchi's concept of non-directive play. If adults are confused by a piece of play equipment, it often means that kids will be all over it. The kids are gonna figure it out. They're gonna attack it. They're going to go and have fun. They're going to make it play. We don't have to tell them how to do that. We can make it safe and last a long time and look beautiful, but man, let them play. This resurgence of abstract playgrounds is still developing, but special destination
这就回到了野口的非指导性游戏概念。如果成年人对一件游乐设备感到困惑，这通常意味着孩子们会在上面玩疯了。孩子们会弄明白的。他们会发起进攻。他们会去玩得开心。他们会让它变得好玩。我们不必告诉他们该怎么做。我们可以让它安全、持久且看起来很美，但是天哪，让他们去玩吧。这种抽象游乐场的复苏仍在发展中，但特殊的目的地
playgrounds are experimenting with new materials and processes. They're able to make forms that would have been astronomically expensive to produce in Noguchi's time. Contemporary designers are now starting to push back against convention and play with more abstract shapes for communities that can afford custom playgrounds. That is. So I feel like there are people that are pushing the envelope. And, you know, it's expensive to start out with, but if more people adopt this equipment,
游乐场正在试验新材料和新工艺。他们能够制造出在野口那个时代生产成本高得天文数字的形式。对于负担得起定制游乐场的社区，当代设计师现在开始反抗传统，尝试更抽象的形状。就是这样。所以我觉得有人正在打破常规。而且，你知道的，一开始成本很高，但如果有更多人采用这种设备，
the price could come down. Although there are no playgrounds in New York City with Nuguchi's name on them, his ideas about imagination and freedom to play have left a deep mark on playground designers and are affecting the emerging playgrounds all around us. Noguchi could have never imagined the long shadow of his ideas. For all he knew, his greatest concepts had never been made.
价格可能会降下来。尽管纽约市没有以野口命名的游乐场，但他关于想象力和玩耍自由的理念在游乐场设计师身上留下了深刻的印记，并正在影响着我们周围不断涌现的游乐场。野口绝不会想到他的理念有着如此深远的影响。据他所知，他最伟大的构想从未被真正建造过。
That's a recording from 1973. At that point, Noguchi had only ever seen one of his playgrounds, kind of built in Japan. A few years later, he'd designed another one in Atlanta, but both of these were nothing close to his true play mountain vision. His own city, New York, had rejected him five times. Never found a way to break through in New York even after Moses was gone for various reasons.
那是一段1973年的录音。当时，野口只见过他的一座游乐场在日本粗略地建造出来。几年后，他在亚特兰大设计了另一个，但这两者都远不能算作他真正的“游戏山”愿景。他自己的城市纽约曾五次拒绝他。甚至在摩西离开后，由于各种原因，他始终没能在纽约打开局面。
There's always a reason, but, you know, hugely frustrating. This was his home. Noguchi's model for a play mountain remained on display in his studio in Long Island City, an unrealized dream in miniature. That is, until January of 1988. A man from Sapporo, Japan, comes and visits Naguchi and is going around his studio in Long Island City. And he says, you know what?
总是有各种原因，但是，你知道的，极其令人沮丧。这里是他的家。野口关于“游戏山”的模型一直陈列在长岛市的工作室里，这是一个未实现的微型梦想。直到1988年1月。一位来自日本札幌的男子前来拜访野口，参观了他在长岛市的工作室。然后他说，你知道吗？
Like, I can get one of your playgrounds built in Sapporo, Japan. At this point in 1988, Naguchi is 84 years old. He goes out to visit this marshy site in Sapporo called Morinuma Park. It's just perfect. This is the spot where play mountain would finally live. Noguchi started designing play structures and earthworks for the park
比如，我可以在日本札幌为你建造其中一个游乐场。到了1988年这个时候，野口勇已经84岁了。他去参观了札幌一处被称为莫埃来沼公园的沼泽地。这里简直完美。这就是“玩耍山”最终将要落户的地方。野口开始为这个公园设计游乐设施和土方工程
with his longtime collaborator, the architect Shoji Sadau. But in the winter of that year, he came down with a cold. And when he came back to New York, it turned into pneumonia. And he died. Noguchi died on December 30, 1988, having designed the vast majority of the park. His collaborator, Shoji Sadau, continued to work on it. From Noguchi's death at the end of 1988, Maura Numa Park took 17 years to build. It finally opened in 2005. It's enormous.
与他长期合作的建筑师贞次良昭（Shoji Sadau）一起。但在那一年的冬天，他感冒了。当他回到纽约时，病情恶化成了肺炎。然后他去世了。野口勇于1988年12月30日逝世，当时他已经设计了该公园的绝大部分。他的合作者贞次良昭继续推进这项工作。从1988年底野口去世算起，莫埃来沼公园花了17年才建成。它最终于2005年开放。它非常宏大。
454 acres. Bacon calls it Noguchi Disneyland. And it's actually five times the size of Disneyland. It is kind of an amalgamation, the greatest hits of all of Nogegu-Chi's un-executed, land, and playground ideas in one spot. It's this huge green swath of land tucked into a bend in the river. There are forests of his candy-like play equipment, mounds and pyramids and swooping paths,
占地454英亩。培根称之为“野口迪士尼乐园”。实际上，它的面积是迪士尼乐园的五倍。它有点像一个结合体，汇集了野口勇所有未实现的土地和游乐场构想中最棒的精华。这是夹在河湾里的一大片绿地。那里有他那些糖果般可爱的游乐设施森林、土丘、金字塔和蜿蜒的小路，
an enormous conical hill to climb, a huge fountain that cycles through an hour-long water show. And we do feel like a tiny version of yourself in this alien city. But most satisfying of all, rising high above this alien landscape, is play mountain. It's totally amazing, it's totally amazing. is play mountain. It's totally amazing. It's totally amazing. Alexandra saw this mountain with her own eyes, a grassy, angular pyramid, surreal in its hugeness at a hundred feet tall. So I went to the Sepuro. It was in October and I parked my bike at the bottom of this flight of like 1000 steps. It's really windy, it's cold, I'm all alone,
一座供人攀爬的巨大圆锥形山丘，一个进行长达一小时水景表演的巨大喷泉。在这座奇特的城市里，我们确实觉得自己变得像个微型人。但最令人满足的是，在这片奇异景观的高处拔地而起的，就是“玩耍山”。这真是太令人惊叹了，太令人惊叹了。就是“玩耍山”。这真是太令人惊叹了。这真是太令人惊叹了。亚历山德拉亲眼目睹了这座山，这是一座长满草的棱角分明的金字塔，高达一百英尺，其巨大的规模超乎现实。所以我去了札幌。那是十月，我把自行车停在大约1000级台阶的底部。风很大，很冷，我孤身一人，
I mean it's like, I'm all alone. I mean, it's like I could be on the moon or something. And I get to the top of the mountain and there's a memorial to No Guchi. And it says, he made this. Isamu No Guchi was never able to take in the view from the peak of his creation. The sculpture he'd spent his whole life dreaming about.
我的意思是，就像，我孤身一人。我的意思是，这就像我可能在月球上或其他什么地方。我到达山顶，那里有一个纪念野口勇的纪念碑。上面写着，他创造了这个。野口勇至死也没能亲眼看到他倾注毕生心血梦想的雕塑的顶峰风光。
A mountain teleported from the wild alien planet of his mind. The one place Niguchi ever felt he really belonged. So it's extremely interesting to me people's place in the world, their sense of belonging, how we function in this planet Earth. I think I have that kind of feeling about sculpture, wanting to be inside the sculpture. It's not just looking at it, it's part of it.
一座从他心灵狂野异星世界传送过来的山。野口唯一真正觉得自己属于这里的那个地方。所以我对人们在世界上的位置、他们的归属感以及我们如何在地球上运转非常感兴趣。我想我对雕塑也有这种感觉，想要融入雕塑内部。这不仅仅是看着它，而是成为它的一部分。
It's your world, it's the world, and the world then becomes a sculpture. Noguchi wanted us to see the world as if we were visiting for the first time, to move our bodies through space as if the simple facts of gravity and contour were brand new delights, to look around with wide eyes, to feel without stretched fingers, and imagine infinite possibilities. In other words, to live like kids on a playground.
这是你的世界，这就是世界，于是世界本身就变成了一座雕塑。野口希望我们以初次造访的眼光看待这个世界，在空间中移动我们的身体，仿佛重力和轮廓的简单事实是全新的乐趣，用睁大的双眼环顾四周，用伸出的手指去感受，并想象无限的可能性。换句话说，就像游乐场里的孩子一样生活。
99% invisible was produced this week by Jackson Roach and edited by Avery Trouffleman, mix in tech production by Sri Fusef, music by Sean Real. Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor Gellani Hall, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Audio of Niguchi comes from a 1973 oral history interview held by the Smithsonian Archives of American Art. Special thanks to Katie Swanson and everyone at Landscape Structures, Janine B. U. N.O.
本周的《99%隐形》由杰克逊·罗奇（Jackson Roach）制作，艾弗里·特劳夫曼（Avery Trouffleman）剪辑，技术制作由施里·富塞夫（Sri Fusef）负责，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Real）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。团队其他成员包括高级编辑杰拉尼·霍尔（Gellani Hall）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、塔伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）、维维安·李（Vivian Lee）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。野口的音频取自史密森尼美国艺术档案馆1973年的一段口述历史采访。特别感谢凯蒂·斯旺森（Katie Swanson）以及景观结构公司（Landscape Structures）的每个人、简妮·B·U·N·O.
and the Isama Niguchi Foundation and Garden Museum. Dayana Wynn, Carlos Morales, and Marfa Public Radio. Tiffany Gomes, Liza Yeager, Marlene Chicagoa, and the Post-In-Community Alliance and Preservation Project, and the staff of the Colorado River Indian Tribes Reservation Museum. We are a project of 91.7KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent in the show on Facebook. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But your digital playground for design stories is at 9iPI.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及野口勇基金会暨庭院博物馆。达亚娜·温（Dayana Wynn）、卡洛斯·莫拉莱斯（Carlos Morales）和马尔法公共广播电台。蒂凡尼·戈梅斯（Tiffany Gomes）、丽莎·耶格尔（Liza Yeager）、玛琳·芝加哥阿（Marlene Chicagoa）以及“后代社区联盟与保护项目”（Post-In-Community Alliance and Preservation Project），还有科罗拉多河印第安部落保留地博物馆的工作人员。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心广播街制作。99%隐形是PRX旗下RadioTopia的成员，我们在Facebook上是一个 fiercely independent（极其独立）的节目。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但你获取设计故事的数字游乐场是9iPI.org。来自PRX的Radio Topia。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。